oh no my n natal Aiden too much of a
good thing that it works so welcome to
council geeks my name is Nathaniel Wayne
I'm joined tonight by Ryan Daly blue and
we're going to be talking about kind of
the little flood of announcements that
came from Fox in regards to the x-men
franchise um cuz things aside from
Deadpool - which you know had it had its
caveny Iseman recently there wasn't a
lot of word on where Fox was going yeah
and I kind of felt like x-men apocalypse
was not met with a lot of critical loves
and I don't think it pulled the doors
off the place in terms of box office
r-rated it didn't I don't it and it's
not even like um like Batman be super
bat for Batman V Superman I don't know
anyone who goes to bat for pocket no it
was just fairly underwhelming so what
they it would they nail down a date for
Deadpool - movie they gave a date for
New Mutants yeah um and one for
officially now called x-men Dark Phoenix
I think the rumors were that it was
x-men supernova which everybody just
assumed was a code for expect our
Phoenix and it I did not think Fox just
figured well they crack the code Michael
call but it is so let's take each of
these kind of in terms so Deadpool -
well first of all because I actually
never got around to doing a video
talking about the casting of Josh Brolin
as cable I'll ask your thoughts on that
first um my first one was okay I don't
have a problem with Kathy Odom I think
you'll be fine
it might not have wildly as much as they
say it does something really crazy like
Pierce Brosnan who was in the were in
the rumor mill for a while act that was
well they were Brad Pitt at one point I
thought that was longshot wishful
thinking up I'm sure he will be fine I I
think you I think he can do what the
part requires which is just to be the
uber masculine straight man to to
Deadpool's slightly effeminate wacky
antics I think for me the thing is is
that every other name that was rumored I
found more interesting than Josh Brolin
is he could do a grizzled warhorse type
of character that's fine and I think he
can do that so you know what I do want
to look I got a gotta remember the name
because they actually announced a while
ago the casting on Domino mmm-hmm woman
by the name of desi beep I'm lazy beats
I have no idea I'm for that banshee her
big claim to fame right now and she's on
the TV show Atlanta so she is she's
black she's african-american um and so I
guess the question what that becomes is
are they going to in some way allow that
to show through or are they going to
bury her under the stark black-and-white
makeup that Domino I mean with Domino as
a character she's not in makeup is what
she looks like but are they going to
bury her in makeup to recreate that look
or are they going to let her her racial
hair to show through more or does it
Adam I'm all for allowing more ethnicity
to shine through but in terms of
covering some of the natural people with
makeup that look so that it doesn't look
like she's had white face or something
but I would look at something like Zoe
Saldana and guardians of the galaxy
who's clearly her skin looks green it
gives her that somewhat alien look but I
still think there's enough of her
natural ethnicity to shine through that
I looked at of it it's not a Caucasian
woman playing that role we I think if
they you do something along that
approach where they make her clearly
like bleach white like paper white skin
so you know it's not natural but you can
still tell the inherit ethnicity behind
it if they can somehow strike that
middle ground I'm cool with that
I'm at about two minds of the thing
because I think I have no doubt I make
what I would say is no judgment on the
creative team involved in that pool
however I have no doubt that it's very
least at the executive level there are
guys thinking please let us bury her
under that makeup
unknown and fewer people will realize
he's black and we won't get the
ridiculous stupid hate mail trolls um
but at the same time will come
regardless I said I almost kind of want
them to poke the bear and let her
natural ethnicities like and find a way
to redesign the makeup so that she's
still if you like just to fit those most
idiots off like how dare you you know
how dare you change the Rays of the
character whose race is in no way
indicative by this color of her skin in
the comic book in the first place no the
thing about the character in the comic
which says she's white with a black dot
around her eye but a domino we could be
the reverse of that that's very real it
would be black with a white guy haha
that would work so New Mutants in April
which first of all is a little bit odd
that it's going to be coming out ahead
of Deadpool considering that it has a
director but no cast so far but the
reason I brought up the Dylan Ami's
times there are some rumors well they're
they have characters listed which means
they probably have a script but they
don't have a confirm cast but the
director right now is known for romantic
mm-hmm stop it is Johnson ajar I
literally had the writer
he did the Fault in Our Stars of the
atom thing that I've seen he did he did
one thing before that the name which
takes another with another romantic
thing easy so that's a little bit of an
odd
he is also I know he has got a shirt or
treatment out there for Stephen King's
The Stand a new adaptation of that
whether or not gonna happen another like
they announced that okay that oh so he's
promised that he's got ambition in
beyond okay like the sort of teen
rom-com young adult type of thing I
think he is trying to expand that said
with a movie like x-men New Mutants a
lot of his cast member will be taken
from that same kind of stock as you know
the Faulkner I mean it by its nature if
a younger cast now the one thing I've
heard I did this is not confirmed but
one of the rumors going around was that
James McAvoy would return in that as
Professor yeah I saw that because I was
looking up and trying to find the darn
thing I found because I saw a list of
character Olsen um that that they're
trying to lock down to appear in this
thing and I saw Professor X listen
really well I mean it's that's based on
some of the source material that he was
kind of there like shepherding these
wall his x-men were taking care of their
own business yeah so some of the
characters that have been mentioned
they include magic the we are narrow
student was Colossus his younger sister
yep Wolfsbane which the name that I have
heard associated with this one is Maisie
Williams also known as Arya Stark from
Game of Thrones
no no converted that idea was just like
it in one of those rumor mill that she
might have been kind of her name was
bandied around that Nicole she turned
into a werewolf died be down for that
coming to her indictable
yeah Mirage who I don't know okay
cannonball what is a character that I
love them I would love to see him in in
the movies sunspots who I think was
actually in Days of Future past as one
of the cabmen father guys who gets
killed early on a warlock who I don't
know Lockheed a little pet dragon dragon
to present um and apparently it's been
rumored that the main intention and I
have to look this up to be sure this
wasn't a junk all of those main
antagonist the room right now is demon
bear I can't imagine that being the big
bad necessarily of analyze actually an
animatic that actually goes with this
like this just been kind of like
storyboarded them fighting this demon
humans from wasn't amused first
adventures it was it was heard by Bilson
cabbage it looks great it's cool it's
just a speak it there hey that would be
harder DiCaprio movie sure made me
afraid back now
here's my big question with this with
doing new mutants at all because New
Mutants has a property made more sense
to me if after apocalypse
underperforming box office and not being
particularly well received and people
not clamoring for a follow-up it
we're just going to drop that those
characters but it's they're not right I
don't see what purpose New Mutants
serves because you know it's then as the
name would imply it's you know the
younger generation of mutants so we've
still got the younger versions of the
main x-men team that we're dealing with
so it doesn't it doesn't it's not a
counterbalance to that it feels like
over a little bit the same thing I think
this is a this is a case of Fox casting
as wide a possible meth as they can
possibly overreaching and getting greedy
and at night and abatement because I
agree with that and I will say off the
three movies that we're talking about
New Mutants is the one that I kind of
want to see just because of its a
different flavor
yeah the next bow the last one on this
list which is x-men Dark Phoenix I don't
really care to see because I don't like
the new characters of a time I love
Cyclops Nightcrawler Jean Grey and and
sort of but I wasn't blown away by them
in x-men apocalypse I really didn't like
sophie Turner as Jean Grey in that movie
so I'm not crazy about seeing her as the
linchpin character of a whole new movie
the x-men the Dark Phoenix saga is one
of the greatest stories in comics ever
told but it might be a story that only
works in a particular context in which
it was told I don't know that it does
train well they haven't done it better
they keep trying to get to the point
where there's going to adapt it and then
they fall down on themselves yeah they
just so you don't know what W will say
they can't like it I don't think it's on
a debt I think not I think I think the
still early cartoon to the melt a job or
not alright I think the thing is is that
the Stoke you can't go out on a mission
we're going to tell the Dark Phoenix or
you need to have told other stories that
have allowed these characters to
marinate enough and then when those
circumstances are right you can when you
try and build direct into that story you
end up being too on-the-nose which is
what we're doing right you need to have
a certain acceptance or affection for
Jean Grey it kind of need to have some
sympathy in some love for Cyclops
and not been able to stick that lady
really well which i think is why they
kind of lean so much to the the Jean
Grae Wolverine love affair yeah well
there was that and it the whole thing is
it's just gonna it it's got to read like
they're not ready for primetime players
because like these characters of Cyclops
and Jean Grey and the entire young team
because apocalypse whether you
particularly care for it or not
apocalypse focused on mystique and
magneto and Xavier again and all these
other characters were side characters so
to suddenly thrust them forward and be
like oh now they're in a termite barely
know them why would I care and the Dark
Phoenix progress is also a cosmic story
with a lot of space alien characters and
things that aren't necessarily part of
the world that Fox's built up yet which
it which is a lot of how last an shot at
some of the focus your billions of this
big epic thing but you created a world
that's too grounded to allow it to
actually be the over over-the-top
operatic thing that it works that and
the new the new reboot of the server's
life confirm Days of Future past and
first-class to apocalypse is sort of
still in that same boat so yeah other
than the basic plot of four powers
corrupt or like taker over like I don't
know what the story is they're actually
going to tell because the I mean
apocalypse didn't just service like
suggest that she has this unlimited font
of power that she might lose control of
but didn't create any sort of exterior
impetus for for generating that Paragon
so I I don't know what story they're
going to tell other than presumably she
loses control and threatens everybody
and spoilers they'll probably have to
tell her off at the end because that's
what happens with the character now that
one done I didn't see that I had a
director
I'm sure Brett Ratner sounded get back
to the server oh boy yeah because that
never goes wrong so right now and now
the list I'm about to get is only comic
book superhero ish movies right now in
2018 we've got black panther in February
New Mutants in April infinity war
may Deadpool in June and man in wasp in
July venom in October Dark Phoenix in
November Aquaman in December and also
that same weekend
the animated spider-man film with Miles
Morales that everyone seems to keep
forgetting is in production which is
that I'm not convinced that will happen
and I'm also not convinced it won't go
dry 50 to do is realize I'm have
expecting that bad but it's still on the
docket for right now so right now this
is what that's 9 a metalic book based
mobius and that's just on yeah that's
not even getting into other stuff that
hits for the same demographic by han
solo Jurassic world and happy beats
where to find them etc etc like another
Universal Monsters movie after The Mummy
to love this here I think there's
another one planned for this year yeah
so this I mean this is really really
packed this is pretty much wall-to-wall
from April through December plus we got
when I was 8 I like lo Black Panther Lee
does the 12 month Yahoo reserve yeah
it's it's really crazy and here's what
makes me nervous because I haven't
bought the argument and the concerns
about superhero fatigue up to this point
I'm afraid that by the end of 2018 I
might be there that was a concern I had
to I was sort of in the saying I was it
the only I didn't think the superhero
movie fatigue would hit just because of
the overexposure of movies I think that
we would get to a point where there's 9
or 10 to the real movies no I'm not sure
any of us did and then by the way I do
think it is worth noting that eight of
the nine are Marvel Comics properties
and 150 City yes oh yeah the model of
Marvel Studios but no because because
Fox has has three of these in learned
and also so many other one or two ton oh
yeah yeah so um yeah but yeah but they
are all from Marvel character and even
though how
banner honored on the logo I will see
the three Marvel Studios movies and I
will say Black Panther is the one that I
have been the most excited about since
it was will announced back in 2014
yeah and I thought were 2014 that was
when I was looking forward to the most
I still like them I'm excited for Black
Panther I'm accepted for aunt naina
Watson except for Avengers infinity war
those three will definitely see I think
I will try and see actual mutants just
to see how different it is what they ate
what they give me
um Deadpool 2 I don't know you were your
right side and then pull in a lot of
people were I wasn't a big fan of
Deadpool 1 and I just it wasn't for me
is not a criticism of the quality of the
movie up I was fine it just wasn't for
me and I don't know if I'll maybe ever
to see the sequel especially in a summer
that's going to be as crowded as yeah
also with a newborn baby and you know
you're just trying to remind yourself
that this is really happening yes is
changing um I also I still think there I
still think there's a Navy Aquaman I
really like Aquaman I don't think I'm
going to see Justice League so I have no
term of reference for what this Aquaman
is going to be but that's that's always
a possibility I don't think that
spider-man the animated one will
actually happen I'm not interested in
the venom I'm not interested in x-men
Dark Phoenix so all those of those 9
there's still four maybe five of them
that I'll end up saying that I'm
interested in for issue four-and-a-half
that I would be that I would want to see
that I would make the effort to go see
well I mean the thing is you said you
know that your previous concerns have
been that fatigue will come when the
movies get bad the thing is I will get a
lineup like that and I think to myself
even if all of these are good I'm going
to be sick of this by the end of the
year I might be the face if there was
one to be a year where we start seeing
things condensed and
a bit like a black hole start to shrink
back down this might be the year but I
mean if I also have this
if we see more in 2019 the one that I
has not let me down yet has been Marvel
Studios I'm and this is the year we're
counting spider-man homecoming the joint
venture between Marvel Studios and Sony
this is the year right now that will see
three of their properties between yeah
in the galaxy volume pure spoken
homecoming info right right
if I live to the end of the year and I
felt like I didn't need that many of the
Marvel Studios movies that would be a
factor to consider going forward to
three years ago around maybe what yeah
two years ago I would have felt
compelled to see every one of these
movies you and I think fans for six was
the rally point that was the first way
like I'm not going to help
oh my god no no and after that it was
just really easy to say 2018 very packed
very good but yeah yeah that that's all
we've got written so I guess that about
wraps it up for this one um
so Ryan Guerra plug anything aside from
your your rapidly approaching offspring
that's really the only thing I can't
think of anything else I've got a number
of podcasts on the fire and water
podcast network
occasionally do guest spots on other
shows I want to say I was supposed to
plug one of them but I just can't think
of what it was maybe kind of midnight in
it maybe next month I'll remember let us
know if we're being way too nit picky
let us let us know if he should be Nick
taking what know let us know if how do i
how yeah uh
should we just shut up and take what we
are given and enjoy the fact that we
were living in this era where we're
getting nine comic book movies I have
known who are we to complain and bite
the hand that feeds us I have no doubt
there were some people will fill that is
the case and they have said as much to
me you're not known for living are you
know what you knew you know they look
native feature about that but if you if
you are watching this in video form
check out the the podcast for the UH net
unexpurgated although that version
become obese podcast available on iTunes
stitcher so in any case thank you so
much for joining us and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]